PROFESSOR: Welcome
to class again.
This time it's not Professor
Forney it's me, so my name is
Ralf Koetter.
You guys have some substantial
chalk here at MIT.
And I'm visiting here from the
University of Illinois, so
Professor Forney thought I could
teach this class here.
All right, let's see.
So I understand that last time,
last Wednesday, you went
through all the finite field
stuff, meaning, so you know
what that would mean,
the finite field.
There's p elements, p
to the m elements.
Whatever q you have here, is a
power of a prime in order to
be a field.
So this one, as a notation,
is a ring of polynomials.
You've seen that too.
So I assume you know everything
about finite fields
that you will need to know here,
at least, except for one
more theorem which Professor
Forney told
me he did not cover.
And this is the fundamental
theorem of algebra.
I have to write a little bit
smaller with this thing here,
otherwise I'll run out.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I know, that's
probably better.
Better.
With the algebra, at least
that's what it's often called,
and really, about 60 percent of
all the proofs in algebra
eventually boil down
to this here.
And what it says is, polynomial
of degree m, f beta
equals zero, at most,
m of beta.
At least, that's one way
to formulate it.
Let me see.
So that's fine.
So what it says is a polynomial
of degree m has at
most m roots.
Once you all have seen that,
probably one way or another,
but because of its importance,
I want to
emphasize it once more.
Do we need a proof of this?
In true MIT spirit we do.
And the proof would go
something like this.
You look at problem number one
in your homework assignment,
and from problem number one, I
could prove that here, too,
but since it's in the
homework, I won't.
You can write the following
given any beta.
Write f of x as f of x is
equal to plus alpha.
Alphas are the field so that's
by some sort of long division
you get to that.
That's what I'm not
going to prove.
Then f of beta is equal zero
is the same as saying that
alpha is equal to zero.
So if either is a root of the
polynomial, zero, it follows
that f of x has this thing here
as a factor, this h of x,
x minus beta, where because of
the degree properties of
polynomials, h of
x is m minus 1.
And so the rest follows
by induction.
So basically, then we can prove
that this polynomial
has, at most, m minus
1 roots, and so on.
And you can descend this route,
and so the rest follows
by induction.
In particular we can say if f of
x has m distinct roots beta
one, beta m, then it factors
completely into the linear
factors like this.
So I just wanted to quickly
state the fundamental theorem
of algebra, since we need it
in a proof later on, and I
think you didn't
go through it.
OK.
So last time, you learned
everything about fields,
finite fields, extension fields,
so chapter eight is
pretty much what we
have to cover now.
What is the whole idea
of chapter eight?
It's linear codes, codes, MDS
codes, and redundant codes.
Oh, by the way, do you have any
questions about this here?
That in any way?
It's pretty straight, right?
OK, so I understand in chapter
six or so, you had already
linear codes over the
binary fields.
So let's just define codes over
a larger field, formally,
a linear code C of length n.
No subspace of Fn.
So whatever the field is.
So F could be any extension
field, could be the binary
field, so it really generalizes
a definition of
code, of what a linear
code is.
OK, so it's a subspace.
What can be derived from that?
Since it's a subspace,
it's a group.
And then we can derive minimum
distance properties.
So let's first define it again,
since it's slightly
different than the definition
for binary codes.
Between Fn, say Fqn.
So I denote the vectors
with an underscore.
I think in the notes, it's
boldface notation, so
translate that online
as I go here.
The distance between two words
x and y, given as dx, the
number of positions that
x_i is unequal to y_i.
AUDIENCE: What's
the subscript?
PROFESSOR: There, a q.
Oh, this is another thing
I should warn you about.
My handwriting is bound to
deteriorate during class.
So I usually start out
reasonably okay, towards the
end of the class it's --
I tell my students to throw
little pieces of chalk at me
when it gets too bad and I'm
not facing them, so please
just say something if
it gets too bad.
So distance is defined
as that, quickly.
So it doesn't really matter
what the values are here.
The x_i and the y_i could
assume different values.
It's a somewhat coarse measure
for the real, the difference
between code words, or
difference between words.
Why do you think I
say it's coarse?
In digital communications
in particular?
Good question, right?
In the end, we want to map that
into a modulation scheme.
In the end, we want to map our
codes that we are deriving
here into modulation schemes.
In the end, we want
to embed them into
some Euclidean space.
Now, different elements of our
alphabet we will map to
different elements in
Euclidean space.
So basically, approximating
their distance relation in
Euclidean space, which we are
really interested in with the
Hamming distance here is pretty
coarse, but we can do,
so we do that.
It's an approximation,
at least.
That clear?
All set?
All right.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] the
Hamming distance
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] the same as
the Euclidean distance?
PROFESSOR: Well, it depends
on the modulation scheme.
It very much depends on
the modulation scheme.
If you have a 8-PSK scheme,
where you would label, put in
the words, here, with three
bit symbols, or with the
symbol from F8, then it's
definitely different.
It's definitely different.
So if you do anti-polar
signaling, then
it's directly reflected.
OK, I'm starting to
digress already.
So just for completeness,
minimum distance, minimum
Hamming, of a code subset Fqn is
d as a minimum code of dxy,
and they have to be different,
it's the same as before.
So now if I claim that --
so the minimum distance of a
code is also given by the
minimum between 0 and x in the
code 0 and x, and this is
minimum of the Hamming weight
of x, and you could
do 0 x in the code.
So that's all old stuff.
I just write it down so
we get started here.
Is that clear, from the
group property, why
this would be true?
So if you just take this, we can
add basically x to both x
and y, just translating
the whole relation
to somewhere else.
So in particular, we translate
it here, once we have it here,
than the distance between 0
and x is just the weight.
OK.
So far, so good.
Now what is next?
Generate a matrix.
This is not really
in the notes, but
I think it's important.
So see, the code here
is a subspace.
It's a linear space, so it
has a generator, it has
generators, k generators.
So let g1 be k, write
this off the code.
So as a basis of the vector
space, that this would be a
basis of the vector space, any
basis would be fine here.
Then C may be defined as all
the x in Fqn such that x is
sum over --
what do I call it --
fi gi, where fi is in Fq.
And the reason I introduce
this, we can --
this is just the definition
of a space, right?
That's clear.
So if you have these generators,
you find a
generator matrix, uh-oh,
it already starts.
Let me --
matrix g which contains,
as a m matrix
containing the rows gi.
So the i-th row in the generator
matrix is just gi.
Then you also can write as x
is equal to f times g, f
element Fqk, or just the same
statement as this one, so
nothing has happened.
So basically, the reason I did
that, I wanted to introduce
the term generator matrix, which
is sort of important.
And one more property of this
orthogonal complement
of C, of the code.
So what does that mean?
So the orthogonal complement of
the code you could write as
Fqn such that sum of x_i
y_i is equal to 0.
The sum is obviously over the
field for all y in the code.
What's the dimension of this, of
the orthogonal complement?
AUDIENCE: n minus k.
PROFESSOR: n minus k, clearly,
because we have ambient space
is n dimensional, we impose k
linear constraints on this, by
the k generators, so the k
dimensions of, take note, by
the generators drop out.
So the dimension of
the orthogonal
complement is n minus k.
So what else do we need
to say about this?
C is called the dual code
for this reason.
C is called dual code.
In particular, it's a code
that's a linear space.
It's a subspace of Fqn
again, it's a code.
So it's just as nice
a code as C at this
point in time at least.
So it's called a dual code.
To C, if it is a code, it
has a generator matrix.
Let h be a generator
matrix for C dual.
So in particular, we could
define C dual now, for
example, by the equivalent
of this relation here.
But because it's a dual code,
we now also can define the
original code in an equivalent
way such that x times h
transpose is 0.
We could define our original
code C either as the image of
a matrix g, of a generator
matrix g, or as a kernel of a
parity-check matrix h.
So h is a ...WRITING
ON BOARD...
for C. So that's all pretty much
straight linear algebra,
and I'm sure you've seen that
in many different places.
Any questions about
any of this?
AUDIENCE: So the addition
of the dual
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
the summation
equals 0 for all [INAUDIBLE]
other than x, right?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Oh no, no, no,
it doesn't have to be
different from x.
If y is in the code, if y is
in C, then x has to be
orthogonal to it.
They can be the same vector,
in particular, if you have
binary vectors, an even
made binary vector is
orthogonal to itself.
It's a little bit odd,
but that's the
magic of finite fields.
OK.
Good.
So these are codes,
now we could stop.
We have defined the object,
and obviously it exists,
because we could just write
something down and it exists.
So once we have defined it,
the next question is, what
sort of codes do exist?
So that's what we're
going to do next.
First, question one.
Codes do, what type
of codes do exist?
So which codes do you know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You know Reed-Muller
codes, you know
probably sporadic binary codes
that are out there.
These are all binary codes.
So what type of codes exist
over larger fields?
Many, many classes.
There exists the equivalent of
the Reed-Muller codes, there
exist QRE Reed-Muller codes,
and there exist generalized
Reed-Muller codes, and,
and, and, and, and.
But we are interested in a
very special class today,
which is MDS codes.
It stands for Maximum
Distance Separable.
It's a strange name.
There's no particular
reason for MDS.
But, let's see what we
can do with that.
What type of codes do exist?
So we have parameters of codes
-- oh, I think you write the
curly bracket, right --
n, k and d.
So that would mean a code of
length n, dimension k, and
distance d.
And let me add something to it
a q, if you want to emphasize
that this is a query field.
So are all numbers
possible here?
What do we have, a 20,
19, 17 code over, I
don't know, over F8.
Is this possible?
What would you think?
No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's not possible.
It doesn't seem likely.
What conflicts here, is the
dimension and the distance.
If you get a large dimension,
in particular, if we would
make this 20, what
would that mean?
It would mean we have to
take the entire space.
If you take the entire space,
then the minimum
weight word is 1.
So this is possible.
You know this is possible.
If you drop this by 1, that
seems very unlikely that we
would get a 17 here.
But what do we get here?
2.
You get a 2 because that's what
we can achieve with a
single parity-check code.
The parity-check code
doesn't have to be
restrained to binary.
Why?
Why would it be restrained
to binary?
You could just, the set of all
vectors let's define the
single parity-check codes s
p c, q, as the set of all
vectors such that sum of
the x_i is equal to 0.
So could we have a word
of weight 1 in here?
Obviously not, right?
If it has a weight 1, how
would it add up to 0?
Because one position
would never cancel
with any other position.
So the minimum weight is
2 here, and we get
a distance of 2.
So what's the next one?
It's tempting to say 3, right?
3, but this is very much
a question, now.
Because this is not as easy
to come by as a single
parity-check.
And that's what we're
going to do next.
We're going to define bounds on
the maximum distance that a
code can have altogether.
OK, so let's do the following.
Which parameter is possible?
OK.
So let's assume you have a code,
an n,k,d code, and now
we want to find a relation, a
bound between n, k and d.
How do we do this?
Any ideas?
Let a computer run for
eternity and find
all possible codes?
No, no, no, no.
We don't do this.
We wouldn't get far.
Let's assume we have
an n,k,d code.
What does that mean?
Well, let's write the code
words all down in a huge
matrix, so each row
in this matrix
corresponds to one code word.
So this has a length n, this is
q to the k, q is whatever
the alphabet is of the code in
question, and now we say it's
an n,k,d code.
What that means, it means, among
other things is, say we
delete, just punch out,
d minus 1 positions.
We punch out d minus 1 positions
of all code words
and we look at the code
that remains.
You guys don't have colored
chalk here, huh?
We look at the code that
remains, it means we look at
this part of the matrix.
Is that clear, what
I'm doing here?
So if the code indeed had
distance d, can there be any
two rows equal in this part?
Remember, we punch out
all d minus 1.
Can there be any rows in this
part that are equal?
No, right?
Couldn't be.
They all have to be different.
What does that mean?
They all have to be different,
but how many different tuples
can we have in this part?
Well, we have at most q to
the n minus d minus 1.
That's the length here.
This n minus d minus 1.
Different tuples.
So how can we patch that
together into a relation on
the parameters?
It basically says, q,
this is q to the k.
q to the k is upper
bounded by this.
It's upper bounded by this.
And let me take the
logarithm on here,
and we get this relation.
That's a first incarnation of
the tension that we get on
code construction, on codes.
And bound on this, at least.
If you choose d large,
the distance large,
then k has to go.
If you choose k large, the
distance cannot be very large.
So this is where we, for the
first time, see this tension.
And it's also important, I'm
sorry that I run around like
this here, n has to be
at least k plus d, k
plus d minus 1.
So here, you see this 28 in 3,
it would just satisfy this.
It would just satisfy this.
So do we know it exists?
No.
No, why would it?
So far, we only have looked at
this here, and so, if it would
exist, it would have
to satisfy that.
But there's no reason
to assume it exists.
At the moment, at least.
OK.
This is called the
Singleton bound.
Any code over any field, phi
n, this relationship on the
parameters.
Good.
Any code satisfying and bound
with equality is called MDS.
So we have an MDS code if and
only if it satisfies the
Singleton bound with equality.
That's the definition
of MDS codes.
And now it makes maybe a little
bit more sense to talk
about Maximum Distance Separable
codes, well, in a
sense, they have the maximum
distance among all codes.
You find all codes with the
given n and k, if they're MDS,
they have the maximum
distance.
OK, let's think about
this a little here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
dependence on q
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's a very
strong dependence on q.
The bound, not.
The bound has no dependence
on q.
If the guys exist or not,
that's very much
dependent on q.
We'll get to that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when the
q is large, we have more
options to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
For binary, there's a very
simple argument to show that
there are no binary MDS codes
except for the parity-check
codes and the repetition
codes and trivial code.
So say we have a binary code,
a binary n,k,d code with a
generator matrix.
So what could the generator
matrix be?
There will be an identity part,
and then there will be
the rest of the generator
matrix, and how could we
possibly fill that in, in
order to make it MDS?
Because this is n, this is k,
and we see in order to make it
MDS, every single row has to
have all entries equal to 1.
Because if not all entries are
equal to 1, here, then we
immediately have exhibited a
code word with a weight less
than n minus k plus 1.
So OK, we know the first row
has to have all 1's.
Because now, the weight of this
row is exactly on the MDS
[INAUDIBLE].
What about the next one?
The next one, same thing.
All entries have to be 1.
But now we see the
problem, right?
Now we add those two guys, it
should again be a code word,
and we have a grade
two code word.
So this is, in a nutshell, to
prove that there are no binary
MDS codes except the
trivial ones.
So the trivial ones are n, n1,
n, n minus 1, 2 and n1, n.
These are the trivial ones.
The space itself, so it's in a
parity-check code, and the
repetition code.
These are the only
binary MDS codes.
And the argument is
roughly there.
OK, where was I?
Yeah, let's think about this
a little bit more.
And we are getting to exactly
your question about the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
This here has to hold, this
argument has to hold
regardless of which d minus
1 positions we punch out.
This argument has
always to hold.
Which means, think about it,
it's an enormously strong
combinatorial condition
on the code.
So you have a code, that means
you have a code, you write it
in a matrix like this,
all the code words.
You punch out an arbitrary
collection of d minus 1one
positions, and the rest, the
remaining positions, have to
make up the entire space here.
The entire space Fqn minus
to that right exponent.
This is a very --
think about it, I mean, just
writing down this is an
enormously strong combinatorial
condition.
So that will actually lead to
the codes existing only for a
very, very special, for a
subset of field sizes.
In particular, like you said, we
have to have enough freedom
in the field size to fill up
this matrix to satisfy this.
OK, before we get to that,
before I say a word about the
field size, let me formalize
what I just said here, namely,
that all of the other positions
have to be exactly
the q to the n minus d minus
1, different tuples.
And the definition, let the
code with q to the k, code
words over alphabet Fq.
Let subset of the positions in
C, i is called an information
set if C constrained to i runs
exactly through all the q to
the k, runs through all
the q to the k.
Fqk.
So what it means is, you have a
code, and you have a subset
of positions, maybe this one,
this one, this one, this one.
This is a subset of positions
if the code words.
So if the matrix that remains
after you take out the
punctured columns, runs through
all the q to the k
elements of Fqk, then this
is an information search.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Constrained to
i, because i has size k.
i is just -- its just about
enough to describe every code
word, if the restraint of C to
the set would indeed be giving
a unique vector for
each code word.
The reason to call it -- so
this is the definition of
information set.
The reason to call it an
information set, it's pretty
straight, right?
Why is it called an
information set?
Because it's enough, right?
Because it's enough.
If you know exactly the value
of a code word in these
positions, then it is
enough to recover
the entire code word.
When some genie tells you, gives
you a code world which
was corrupted by noise or
something, but tells you,
these k positions are OK.
That's enough, that's
all you need.
That's an information set.
You can recover the information
from them.
Actually, it is an application
that pops up sometimes.
That somehow, you get side
information about some
positions in the code word
indeed being correct, and
others not.
And others you don't
know about.
So that's the information set,
with respect to our MDS code.
So with respect to our MDS code,
a corollary of the thing
that involved any k positions
in an MDS code,
an information set.
So any k positions on
information set.
It's a really strong property.
Really strong combinatorial
property.
OK, so far, so good.
This is so strong, this
property, that we can say
something about these codes even
without even knowing if
they exist.
So, so far, we have talked about
these codes as if we
knew they existed.
Well, it's not entirely trivial,
since we know those
guys here exist.
So it's not entirely empty,
we're not out in
cuckoo space, here.
But do any other one exist,
except for those?
That's the question.
We don't know that yet.
We will show in a little while
that they do, but we don't
know that yet.
But the interesting part is that
we can derive properties
of those codes without even
knowing they exist.
And how do we do that?
For example, we want to derive
the following property, how
many words of weight d exists
in linear MDS code?
One could ask that, right?
If they exist, they're nice,
and if they exist, we also
want to know how many words do
exist at minimum distance.
Because that translates, again,
directly into union
bound arguments later on, and
probability of error.
So that's a good question.
How many words of weight
d exist in a MDS code?
Let's call this n d, and we
want to know how many.
So I'll let you think about this
for a sec while I erase
the board, and then somebody
will tell me the answer.
So how can we think
about this?
Let's try to do a similar
argument as this one.
Let's look at a single word,
and let's assume that d
positions, we ask the questions
does there exist a
code word within the
first d positions?
It is equivalent to the
question, does there exist a
code word that covers exactly
all d positions?
Any set of d positions.
AUDIENCE: 0 everywhere else?
PROFESSOR: And 0 everywhere
else.
Why is that nice?
If you could prove that, that
there exists a word for all d
positions, because then, we
pretty much know what happens.
Then we know that, well, if this
is true, then there are n
choose d ways to choose
those d positions.
And then within those d
positions, and since it's a
linear code, we can multiply
with the q minus 1 on the
repeated element.
So if we can choose our d
positions arbitrarily, then
this is the number over
words at distance d.
So let's look at a word, and
let's, without loss of
generality, assume it's
a first d positions.
So the first d positions.
So in particular, these would
be the first d minus 1
positions, which would mean
that this have length k.
So if we have an MDS code, this
is an information set.
So if this is an information
set, then we can fill up this
thing with just about
anything we want.
So we choose this information
set to be equal to 1.
This is how we choose this
information set, and by the
property of MDS code, we are
guaranteed that there exists a
code word which is this part
in the information set.
But we also are guaranteed it's
a weight d word, right?
The minimum distance is d,
that means all of these m
entries here, they must all
be non-zero, in this part.
Otherwise, it wouldn't
have weight d.
OK?
And there we have it.
That was all we needed to show.
Right?
Because now we have shown that
there exists a word of weight
d in the first d positions.
Is that clear?
Let's try again.
I will say the same words.
Maybe it becomes clearer
by that.
Let's look at a code word.
This is a generic code word,
at first, and we want to
answer the question, does
there exist a code word
within, which has support only
in the first d positions?
So does there exist a code word
which is non-zero here,
up to d, and which is zero
everywhere else?
That's the question
we want to answer.
OK.
Now here's what we do.
We look at this road and
say, you know what?
Let's look at the last k
positions, which have an
overlap of 1 with
this word here,
because it's an MDS property.
So we have this relation
between n, k, and d.
And since any k positions in
the word are in information
set, so we can choose whatever
we want in this part, and this
is what we choose.
By the property of MDS codes,
this corollary, we are
guaranteed there exists the code
word which in the second
half of the code word
looks like this.
And in the first half,
it looks different.
There's something else here, and
I say, well it cannot have
any 0 in here, because
then it would have
weighed less that d.
So it has non-zeros here.
So indeed, we have shown the
existence of a code word which
has non-zeroes in the
first d positions.
Very simple.
And that was without
loss of generality.
You could make the same argument
for any d positions.
What have we shown?
We have shown that indeed, we
can choose any d positions in
the code to support the
minimum weight code
word of weight d.
This is how many ways we can
choose this, then we have to
multiply it with q minus 1.
All non-zero field elements.
The reason is, we might have
chosen this, or we might have
chosen omega or omega squared
here, or just the multiples,
the scalar multiples of it.
Interesting, right?
This property, that any k
positions on information set
is really strong enough
to prove the --
actually, it's strong enough
to prove the entire weight
distribution of an MDS code.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no,
why no, no, no, no.
So then you would
get too much.
If you write q minus 1 to the
d, then you would want to
multiply each position with
a different value.
That would imply that there's
more than one code word in the
first d positions.
More than one code word so
that they are not scalar
multiples of each other.
If that would be true, then
you could find a linear
combination which is still
0 in this part, but has
additional 0 here somewhere.
But if that is true,
then we don't have
enough distance anymore.
Then it's not an MDS code.
All right, so it's
indeed q minus 1.
Within each d positions, we have
one dimensional space.
It's just one dimension.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
far off minimum weight
code words?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah,
definitely.
Any other code must have less,
so it would have less.
But every other code
would have a
smaller minimum distance.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Suppose we let the last k minus
1 position zero, and the
one before that,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
And you said that we can do it
for any of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
total field?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Since it's a linear
code, some of those code words
should be in the linear
code, right?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So because it's a
field, also we are going to
[INAUDIBLE]
there exists an inverse
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So if we add those two
code words, we should have
all zero, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
k minus 1, and have inverse
at the one before.
We get that code word which has
a minimum weight, which is
less that the one
we have here?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
There is a trick out.
There's a way out of this.
Great argument.
But there's a trick out.
AUDIENCE: There's gotta
be an upper bound
PROFESSOR: No, no, there
is a trick, there
is a way out here.
Namely, so let's put
it like this.
Right here we put in a 1, just
for simplicity, let's assume
all the other positions
are also 1.
And then you say, this would
be another code word, which
has here an omega.
I say, you know what?
What's going to happen?
All the other positions are
going to be omega 2.
There's no way to combine
these two guys to get an
additional 0, unless
you get all 0's.
Unless you get to 0.
That's what I said, it's
a one-dimensional
space in these positions.
When it's a soft code .
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: It tells you that if
you write down the minimum
weight code words in the q minus
1 times d matrix, that
is, you have a Latin
square, basically.
That's what it tells you.
There's in no position, if you
have anywhere in here an
element alpha and element omega,
the same omega pops up
nowhere else.
There's ramifications of MDS
codes in combinatorics left
and right, so this would
be a Latin square.
You know, you can learn a lot
a lot about MDS codes if you
think a little bit about that,
and about combinatorics
altogether.
OK, where was I?
So we know that's fun.
And actually, in the homework,
you going to do n d plus 1.
So the next one.
But once you do n d plus
1, do all of them.
In a sense it's just inclusion
and exclusion from then on.
The first one is sort of the
toughest one, the rest is
inclusion exclusion.
And just for the heck of it,
when you go home and do the
homework, write them all out.
It's a pretty looking
formula, in the end.
OK, so far, so good.
So we have still talked about
MDS codes without knowing if
they exist.
Except for the trivial
ones here.
And the existence of MDS codes
is actually not known for
which parameters they exist.
So I give you a research
problem.
The research problem is the main
conjecture on MDS codes.
And it's always sort
of tricky.
When a research problem
has a name, then
that signifies danger.
Then it means that
it's not trivial.
The question is, for which k
d and q, for which sets of
parameters n k d q, do
MDS codes exist?
And the conjecture this is that
n k q, because in MDS
code we can actually get
rid of the d here.
e, the longest length
of an MDS code.
The longest length of an MDS
code, I mentioned k over an
alphabet of size q.
The conjecture is that n, k, d
is less than q plus 1 for k at
least 2, unless --
I always have to
look that up --
I think 2q.
And k plus 1 for k
greater than q.
We talk about it in a second,
except that n, there's
a 3, 2 to the s.
So if the alphabet is a power
of 2, alphabet size an
extension field of
2, basically.
q plus 2 and q minus
1 q to the s.
q plus 2.
OK, so this is the main
conjecture on MDS codes.
Basically, it says that the
length can essentially be as
large as the alphabet size,
but not larger.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This q, yeah?
Oh, yeah, n k q, sorry.
It doesn't make sense
otherwise.
So the lengths can be in the
same order of magnitude as the
alphabet size.
That gives enough room, enough
choices, to fill up this
matrix with the information set,
with the MDS property on
the information sets.
This is the parity-check code,
this row is just taken out as
a trivial code.
And then, the demon of
mathematics conspired that
this would also be true.
So if you have an extension
field of 2, and you want to
give it a dimension three, MDS
code, they exist for q plus 2.
Right.
There are, of course, reasons
for this, but they go pretty
deep, why they exist for those
parameters, and this is just
mysterious.
One can give reasons,
so on another hand,
it's just so, right.
There are exceptionally enough
that they have names.
The first one is the Hexacode,
it's something with a
generator matrix, and
this goes over F4.
So that's an MDS code of length
six, so this is a n6,
3, 4, MDS code over
alphabet size 4.
That's the first one, in
that sequence here.
Anyway.
Otherwise, we have
this conjecture.
If you solve this, you are going
to be rich and famous,
you're going to live
in Hollywood, and
maybe, maybe not.
But you're going to be probably
not rich, you're
going to be famous about a
couple of hundred people who
know about this MDS conjecture,
but very smart
people have been looking for
this for a long, long time.
OK.
All right, 20 minutes left.
So it's better we define, we
make sure those codes exist.
Do we have any question about
this MDS conjecture?
OK, last 20 minutes, let's
at least make sure
those things exist.
Reed-Solomon codes.
So Reed-Solomon codes
cover this case.
They are examples of codes
which lie, which
satisfy this equality.
OK, so how do we define
Reed-Solomon codes?
Now, just in a true
mathematician spirit, write
down consider the following.
Consider the following code.
See?
Beta 0 beta q minus 1.
The beta i are the distinct
field elements, the distinct
elements in the finite field.
f is a polynomial.
f is a polynomial, and the
degree is less than k.
OK, good.
So we have defined a code.
So what that means is we
start from polynomials.
The set of all polynomials
of degree at most k.
So what do we know
about that set?
It's a vector space, right?
The set of all polynomials
of degree at most k.
We can add them to get a
polynomial of degree at most
k, we can multiply them with a
scalar to get a polynomial
with degree at most k.
It's a vector space.
So we take this vector space and
evaluate for any element
in that vector space.
This element in all non-zero
elements of the field and we
get a code.
We get a set of vectors,
so we get a set of
vectors, and that --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I took
all elements.
Why not?
Why not all elements?
Strictly speaking, I should have
taken one more in order
to get the one here.
We can talk about
that in a sec.
But this one more element
would be --
so it's a code.
First of all, it's a code.
Right?
We all see it's a code.
And once you see it's a code,
we ask, what are the
parameters?
The parameters.
So length, length
is the easy one.
Well, it's q.
What is dimension?
Dimension of C. What's
the dimension?
It's a little bit tricky,
that question.
I actually, at Illinois,
we have to
take a class on teaching.
How to become an effective
teacher.
And one of the things they told
us is that if you ask a
question, you have to wait for
12 seconds to get an answer.
So what's the dimension?
There you go.
This mapping, this mapping
from a vector space to a
vector space.
This mapping, also
called evaluation
map, is a linear map.
It's a linear map, meaning
that, well, let's start
differently.
Let's start differently.
Do any two polynomials map
to the same code word?
That you know.
That you cannot.
Are there any two codes, two
polynomials, so are there f of
x, g of x, such that f of beta
0, so that they coincide in
all positions?
No, then they would be
the same, right?
And the reason is because if
there would be something like
that, then you could just look
at h is f of x minus g of x,
which is just another polynomial
of degree k.
And this would have to vanish
in all positions.
If k is less than q, it could
not possibly vanish in all
positions, because then the
polynomial of degree k would
vanish in more than
k positions.
Fundamental theorem
of algebra.
The very beginning.
So the dimension of C is indeed
k, the same as the
dimension of this
vector space.
The dimension of the vector
space of polynomials of the
degree k minus 1.
And the distance, if k
is less than q, the
distance is equal to q.
The distance, what is it?
Same argument, roughly
the same argument.
I think that's a linear code, so
if it's a linear code, the
minimum distance of the code
is the same as the minimum
weight of a non-zero word.
What's the minimum weight
of a non-zero word?
These are polynomials
of degree k minus 1.
What's the minimum weight
of a non-zero word?
Well, we start out with the
weight 1, and whenever the
polynomial evaluates to 0, one
of the weights drops out.
So I claim the minimum distance
as the minimum
weight, weight of the non-zero
word, and this is n minus,
well, if any of these
polynomials vanishes in all,
it vanishes in at most,
k minus 1 positions.
At most, k minus 1 of these
vectors here, of these
entries, is equal to 0.
So it drops by, at
most, k minus 1.
Drops by at most, k minus 1.
And there we have it.
There we have it.
There we have, oh, this is q.
There we have that the minimum
distance of the code satisfies
this equation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: The dimension?
PROFESSOR: The dimension.
So, it's the same argument,
roughly.
So I say, the dimension, so
let's just say the size of the
code is q to the k.
When is the size of the q to the
k, if no two elements in
the space evaluate to
the same code word?
But if two of them would
evaluate to the same code
word, then we would less size
than the vector space had.
But if two of them evaluate to
the same code word, that means
this is true for all
four positions.
Then we could define a
polynomial h of the
degree k minus 1.
which disappears in more than
k minus 1 positions.
I mean, all positions.
Cannot be, hence the size of
the code is q to the k, so
this is a linear map,
dimension is k.
OK.
So cool.
So we have it, right?
We have our MDS codes.
They exist.
Here they are.
They are Reed-Solomon codes.
Not all MDS codes are
Reed-Solomon codes, but the
ones we are interested
in, they are.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, the distance is
at least this, but the MDS
bounds is at most this,
so it's equal to this.
But the MDS bounds, so the
MDS bound has this is.
So with that.
So it's indeed, they lie exactly
bang on to this.
There are MDS codes,
Reed-Solomon codes.
So that is good.
So we know what they are.
So incidentally, where do you
think this one more point is
that you would evaluate
our polynomials in?
You've heard about projective
geometries?
There's one more point,
it's infinity.
You have, basically, if you look
at the numbers, in order
to close it up, you want to
add infinity to that, too.
In order to get this one more,
this one addition in length,
you want to evaluate this
also at infinity.
You will have opportunity to
do that in the homework.
I looked at the homework and
I was pleased to see this
problem there.
I hope you will be
pleased, too.
OK, all right.
Any questions about this?
Let's see what else
I wanted to say.
Because it just gives me a few
minutes to talk about a few
properties of Reed-Solomon
codes, a few properties of
Reed-Solomon codes.
And what did I want
to say there?
On nested codes, so an RS code
with parameters n k, maybe we
define them [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
like this.
q is properly contained,
k minus 1, minus 1.
This is pretty straight from
the definition of RS codes.
The set of polynomials of
degree at most k minus 1
contains the set of polynomials
of degree at
most k minus 1.
So they are nested codes,
property one.
You will see this is important,
that they are
nested codes, for various
constructions where
Reed-Solomon codes take
part in later on.
A punctured RS code is
again an MDS code.
Why is that so?
Well, you see it?
Say if you puncture a
Reed-Solomon code.
That means we just choose to not
evaluate our code in this,
this position.
And this field element.
Well, we just drop
that coordinate.
Does anything change in the
arguments we have made?
Well, the length is now 1 less,
the dimension, well, the
dimension is still the same,
as long as k is not larger
than the length of the code.
The distance, still the same as
the length, the distance is
at least the length minus
the number of 0's.
So that equation still holds.
Well, but that's
all we needed.
Still MDS code.
So there was really no --
it was not important.
It was not important if you took
all field elements, or a
subset of the field elements
with MDS property.
That has nothing
to do with it.
In particular, we often
in the end, we often
will drop the 0 element.
We often choose not to evaluate
these polynomials in
the 0 of the field.
A punctured Reed-Solomon
code is an MDS code.
So what else did I want
to say about this?
What else did I want
A generator matrix.
How would a generator
matrix look like?
Yeah, how would it look like?
Basically, we can come
from here, right?
We can take the generators
of that space.
So basically, we
say that one --
generate the set of polynomials,
that vector space
of polynomials with --
so this is the basis of
that vector space.
So if we map that basis, then we
get a basis of the image of
the mapping.
And the mapping of that
basis would give this.
So we evaluate the function
1 in all field elements --
gives us 1.
We evaluate the function x
in all field elements.
This gives us the next
generator of the
Reed-Solomon code.
Well, 0 gives 0, 1 gives, oh,
let's write like this.
We evaluate it in all
field elements.
These are all the
The next one, and this
goes up to beta --
OK, so this would be
a generator matrix.
That's fine.
So now, in order to make things
a bit more interesting,
do you have to stop five
minutes early?
We just started five
minutes late?
OK then, I think that's over.
I think it's over.
One more thing for you guys to
think about until you reach
home, then the rest
you do next time.
So let beta 0 be equal to 0
beta 1, or beta i equal to
omega i minus 1 where omega
is primitive in the field.
Then we can write the
matrix v of omega.
I tend to see that the first k
columns, the first k rows of
this matrix would be a
generator matrix of a
Reed-Solomon code.
Of course it's the same
as [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
If we now delete the first
position, we erase the first,
we puncture the first position
all out, and we look at the
rest of the matrix.
This factor of the matrix.
Does this remind anybody
of anything?
It's a DFT, it's a Fourier
transform.
And that's what we start
with next time.
So think about why this is
a Fourier transform.
And maybe that's
a nice analogy.
So we get the distance.
The distance is at least
something, which means it's
not impulsive.
It's not a single 1 somewhere.
The vector that we get
is not impulsive.
Maybe it has something to do
with the bandwidth constraint
and the frequency domain.
That's what you have to
think about on the way
home, and that's it.
Thanks so much.